today uh what's going to happen is that
japanese people are going to imitate
what english sounds like to them
all right so we don't get us an idea
cause you guys already do it at your
place okay we do it all the time oh
ching chong ching chong okay you guys
always do the [ __ ] same [ __ ] so
let's hear what they hear when they hear
this stuff
whoa
you it's very very very
this man just said berry berry berry
which is more uh
yes
we didn't know what the [ __ ] they would
say but it was exactly that
way man
listen
listen that's the language pack that
every homeless person comes with
that's a language bad has a language
pick
there's english and there's homelessness
and they start looking at you like you
don't understand me stupid
you ever had a homeless person have the
audacity look at you like you're the
[ __ ] one yeah it's like they're
trying to emulate
james brown
what'd i say
what i say
what i what i say i got it
yes
you said the same thing
right that [ __ ] in a random yell yeah
you know all
and you get some [ __ ] one two three
[ __ ]
[Music]
pull this in the favor
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
mcdonald's who asked me for food brought
him a burger he said where's my fries
and drinks okay you
are unbelievable
dick and cheese for treating where's my
dolla
i don't know
if
yeah we need to take care of the country
and that's what he was yeah yeah that
was actually pretty good this was some
activist kind of yeah
yeah that was pretty good
for you
[Music]
california girl trying to explain some
[ __ ] like i really don't know yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's fine you know what's
great about they got the mimic you know
what's great about this is it comes out
of them so natural that you can tell
that they make fun of english-speaking
people like that at home yeah they're
practicing they didn't just come from
nowhere yeah yeah yeah they definitely
try to say a few words
[Music]
hey shout out to this man look yes lady
i appreciate that okay always subbed
over dumped okay
okay
that's it the people who watch things
dub they're subhuman to me
absolutely not
when someone sends me a dubbed anime i'm
like are you are you a [ __ ] lost
child do you want to be homeless soon
what's wrong with you
why
there's no reason
okay if i'm being serious
the original voice
shares the inflection of what the
character was saying in the way that
they wanted to say it voiceovers never
do it justice so the mouth and the way
that the person is speaking in the
language that they're speaking affects
everything and so to just put a voice
over i always think it just makes it way
worse yeah i think i i like
i like a dumb anime better than a dub
real life the dub real life i can't do
it the synchronization of the lips
doesn't match with it oh and it get it
gets it gets to me
that makes sense
but with anime the thing is like
japanese dialogue is kind of corny
to like a degree that's not normal so
hearing it in english just removes my
ability to accept what the [ __ ] they're
saying
oh my god you look so pretty you've
grown so much i'm not this is easter
that's right right there this might be
the best one i've heard so far even
though she said a few words like
beautiful she killed it yeah but the
internet is the intonation that was the
mom yeah that's how they see us
[ __ ]
united states america
he said nothing
but he tried
hey man that just sounded like uh
konichiwa can i eat some sushi
that's what it was that's exactly what
the [ __ ] that was
[Music]
understand it yeah
this guy spent a little bit too much
time on world star hip-hop
and that's the only thing he knows about
americans yo yo yo yo yo yo
[Music]
english no english uh no english music
speaking english no no no
this may sound like he was debating
himself english english no no no english
no english no no no no started sounding
like morse code halfway through yeah
[Music]
that was french
that was french very good friends by the
way just i could i saw your chin raised
a little bit you know what i mean it
almost sounds like you have a smile
it smells like [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
it sounds like that sometimes your
friends sound like that yeah and you
know what
we speak french and we just yeah that's
how you sound uh yeah yeah i'll be
catching myself it depends it depends
what kind of friends that was like
french
like repelling friends like you know
not deciding i put them on the same
bucket like i know there's a bunch of
people who watch us who like live in
bordeaux or
we're different but i'm like i don't
care it's like i don't want to see the
nuance in french people to me you guys i
put you all in the same paneer
it's like but there's an old man friends
that you know uh that's always arguing
on tv
when you compare them to parisians yeah
but i'm like listen different bakery
same baguette shut your mouth some
croissants
i shouldn't have fun nothing with them
in bed never love me
it's not like a french girl's beginnings
i see your point i see your point but i
was not thinking that at all like i
found it
today i wish to show you something very
beautiful my vagina
what
what
let me just say when you speak french
and people learn you can speak french
and you're in america they get excited
oh yo you speak another language
they get crazy
another language that's not spanish
they're like
yeah
yeah yeah because you speak spanish oh
are you part mexican i'm like no [ __ ]
other people speak spanish
bizarre guy was like oh you speak french
yeah
why
it's like because it's my first language
no
what are you talking about
because i can't hear an
[Laughter]
what does japanese sound like to you why
don't we make the same thing right now
you're not a samurai what's this what's
going on that's what i watch
well why did your shoulders come up here
like
that that's villains samurai villains
that's what i know that [ __ ]
don't speak it's about japanese to me oh
i saw this guy get there go home tony
there you go
i don't i don't know that [ __ ]
i don't know i just do this i just know
these whenever everything is all in
there
i shouldn't you know all that [ __ ] i
used that when i was like yeah when i
didn't see english it was gibberish me
my sister was english gibberish yo not
me not missing a terrible time it turks
man
that's crazy
we used to [ __ ] english different
rich all the time yeah yeah man go for
it pentatonic turrets
like i mean phone something about martin
facts
facts
that was that's what we used to do kids
every kids here used to gibberish in
english let me show you something
you ready yeah can't believe that mori
album john
did you fly by the love black call yeah
i come by the metronome
i played that probation by the wrong
front line today
oh the raising man of the national
marine time for me you greet that trajan
no first station is traffic i was like
am i having a brain attack why don't i
understand [ __ ]
what is going on hold on let me make a
complete sentence hello my name is eric
i don't smell burnt toast what the [ __ ]
is going on but it's good yeah it's
[ __ ] good
vanilla prawns around for mom's
predation sex speaking for that [ __ ]
uh what what bro i can't watch this [ __ ]
i think i'm doing like a brain damage
[ __ ] like i i can't understand [ __ ]
that's going on but it's good it's it's
very well done this was the whole thing
laura's day you pour along for that
yeah sure
so i can sew that lawn flight you want
for uh for the ratchet shoes and um
yeah chad's a long way for the rainbow
seasonal and uh all that kind of
[Music]
yeah it's well done it's well done it
makes you think that you got brain
damage yeah it's well done that's what
i'm saying so i understand why people
that's what it sounds like
what they're saying it [ __ ] you up
it's super well done but whatever
i really thought i was like i can't
understand [ __ ] yeah it's really
confusing but anyways that's it for
today's video let us know what you guys
think in the comments below is it
confusing for you is there a certain
language where it sounds like gibberish
and why most languages probably but is
there one particular that you've learned
or anything like that we want to hear
from you